- [Voiceover] Let's look
at this clock and see
if we can tell what time is shown on it.
First thing, when we look at a clock,
we have two hands and that's because time
is told in two parts.
Time is told in hours,
that's part.
And on a clock the hours are represented
by the short hand,
and then the other part is minutes.
And on an analog clock like this one,
minutes are represented by the long hand.
So let's look first at hours.
We have the short hand,
and it's between the six and the seven.
What that means is it's after 6 o'clock,
but not quite seven,
'cause the hour hand started at the top
and worked its way around and it's gone
past 6 o'clock,
but it's not seven.
So it's six something.
Six something.
It might be 6:15, might be 6:45.
We'll figure out the minutes next,
but we know it's after 6 o'clock
but not a seven.
So we'll put a six in our hours place.
Then for minutes we have this longer hand
which is pointing right here at this mark.
And minutes, again, start at the top
and work their way around.
But now each of these
little spaces is one minute.
So we can go one, two, three, four, five,
and when we get to this first square,
this first where this one is,
we've gone five minutes.
Let's keep going like that.
Six, seven, eight, nine,
10 at this next one,
and maybe you see a pattern here.
Every time we get to one of these numbers
or the squares, the bigger marks,
we've gone five more minutes.
So if we keep going this will
be 15 minutes past the hour.
Keep going.
20.
25.
Now we can't go all the way to the six
because our minute hand stopped here.
It hasn't reached this part.
So after 25, we'll go
back to counting by one,
is the one minute.
We have 25, 26, 27.
The minute hand has gone
past 27 of these marks,
meaning that it is 27
minutes past the hour.
Let's try another one.
The hour hand is between
the four and the five,
which means it's after 4 o'clock.
It's some amount of minutes after four,
but it is not yet five.
And now let's look at our minute hand.
The longer hand represents minutes.
So the minute hand started at the top
and it's gone five, 10, 15,
not quite to 20,
so let's go back to 15
and then count by ones.
16, 17, 18, 19.
Our minute hand lines up to 19.
So it is 19 minutes after four, or 4:19.
On this one I encourage
you to pause the video
and see if you can figure out the time.
Okay, let's try it together now.
So the hour hand, between
the seven and the eight.
So it's after seven, but not quite eight,
and by looking at the hour hand we can see
it's quite a bit after seven 'cause
it's almost eight.
And looking at the minute hand,
confirms that the minute hand's gone
all the way to here.
It's almost back to the top.
And that minute hand, starting at the top,
has gone five, 10, 15, 20,
25, 30, 35, 40,
45, and one more, 46 minutes past.
46 minutes past seven.
The time is 7:46.